aquí tengo un libro e imaginemos que
aquí va a haber un espejo lo que quiero
hacer es tomar un punto arbitrario de
este libro y bueno les comento que este
libro va a estar iluminado por una
fuente de luz que no sabemos exactamente
dónde está y ya que este libro no es
brillante o brilloso va a reflejar la
luz de manera difusa así que si yo elijo
un punto arbitrario en este libro por
ejemplo acá voy a elegir dos rayos de
luz que salen de este punto del libro
uno de estos rayos
va a salir por acá
se va a reflejar así con el mismo ángulo
de incidencia se va a reflejar y ahora
vamos a dibujar otro rayo que sale
exactamente desde este mismo punto
recordemos que aquí la luz se va a estar
difundiendo de manera radial por lo que
voy a dibujar ahora otro rayo pero que
va a tener otro ángulo de incidencia
antes voy a extender un poco mi espejo
para que alcancen a reflejarse bien los
rayos de luz y ahora si este rayo va a
más o menos por acá
llega aquí y se va a reflejar con el
mismo ángulo
ahora imaginemos que aquí tenemos a una
persona que está observando esto aquí
está su ojo
voy a tratar de dibujarla lo mejor que
pueda pero ustedes disculparán si no me
salen muy bien los dibujos
normalmente me gusta dibujar pero como
que hoy no me están quedando muy bonitos
los dibujos pero bueno vamos a darnos
una idea
y qué es lo que va a estar viendo esta
persona de acá recordemos que la
realidad es son una simulación que está
ocurriendo dentro de nuestro cerebro
esta persona ver a ambos rayos de luz y
aparentemente para esta persona ambos
rayos van a divergen de un punto en
común permíteme poner otro ejemplo
imaginemos que aquí tenemos una naranja
aquí está una naranja más o menos así y
vamos a llenar el momento lo que está
ocurriendo aquí a la izquierda aquí
dónde está la naranja no hay espejos ni
reflejos ni nada vemos cierto punto en
la naranja y la luz de este punto va a
divergir de manera radial es decir va a
emanar luz hacia todas partes a partir
de este y si yo observo estos rayos de
luz en mi cerebro
veré que estos rayos salen de línea
recta del punto que estoy observando lo
mismo va a ocurrir en el lado izquierdo
en esta parte que acabo de dibujar
nuestro cerebro no va a intuir que esto
es un rayo reflejado para nuestro
cerebro
estos dos rayos de luz van a converger
de un punto en común si yo extiendo
estas líneas como lo procesa nuestro
cerebro
más o menos así
más o menos así van a converger o se van
a unir en un punto va a lucir como que
si ambos rayos de luz partieron de este
punto permítanme hacer un poco de
espacio aquí
para que pueda caber lo que me falta
dibujar esto lo quito lo pegó me falta
el ojito no se preocupen ahorita también
me llevó este ojito y como les comentaba
la realidad es que aquí en esta parte no
existe objeto alguno no hay nada atrás
del espejo pero para el observador
pareciera que aquí hay un objeto y de
hecho si este punto corresponde a este
punto del libro si hiciéramos esto para
todos los rayos de los que emanan del
libro nosotros veríamos o esta persona
vería algo más o menos así
y sabemos que atrás del espejo no existe
pero nuestro cerebro la forma en la que
nuestro cerebro procesa la información
visual nos hace creer que sí
existe
ahí está
y esto no es algo ajeno a nuestra
experiencia cotidiana con los espejos
esa es la imagen que esta persona está
viendo en el espejo y la imagen
reflejada va a tener estas letras
volteadas para aclarar esto puedo
dibujar otro rayo aquí en otra esquina
del libro acá va a emanar más o menos
así hoy mis rayos de los no son muy
derechos pero ustedes captan la idea y
se va a reflejar
de manera que la persona va a extrapolar
esta línea y va a visualizar la que sale
hacia atrás y que viene de este punto de
acá por lo que va a quedar una imagen
invertida del libro todo esto lo hago
para que ustedes se familiaricen con la
manera en la que funcionan los reflejos
y para que también se familiaricen con
el concepto de imagen virtual esto de
aquí es una imagen virtual
imagen
virtual
y en el siguiente vídeo la compararemos
con una imagen real en 7 forma la imagen
virtual es más intuitiva para nosotros
por toda la experiencia que tenemos con
los espejos y lo llamamos virtual porque
el objeto en realidad no se encuentra
que no existe un espacio físico dentro
del espejo es nuestra mente la que usa
esta imagen divergente y crea un modelo
en nuestro cerebro dando la impresión de
que aquí existe un objeto cuando la
fuente de luz se encuentra en realidad
acá
puede ser otro diagrama ya que los
diagramas normalmente no tienen ese tipo
de perspectiva
este otro diagrama les dará el mismo
sentido pero los haga familiarizarse con
lo que normalmente encontramos al
estudiar sobre espejos y lentes está
es la tierra aquí hay un espejo y
digamos que va a haber una persona
parada enfrente y de hecho voy a poner
aquí una flecha que va a simbolizar a un
objeto o una persona que se encuentra
frente a este espejo a claro este no es
un rayo de luz es un objeto una persona
o un objeto físico pensamos en la imagen
de esta flecha si esta flecha fuera una
persona y tuviera ojos que vería bueno
tenemos un punto arbitrario en esta
flecha por ejemplo acá y vamos a
imaginar un rayo de luz que va derechito
hacia el espejo pues qué va a pasar se
va a reflejar en la misma dirección
quizás llega hasta los ojos de esta
persona y ahora vamos a dibujar otro
rayo de luz que sale del mismo punto
pero con un ángulo de incidencia
diferente por lo que este rayo de luz va
a salir así
y se va a reflejar de esta manera para
simplificar la cosa imaginemos que toda
esta flecha en lugar de ser una persona
va a ser un ojo va a ser un ojo aquí
está el iris
el párpado las pestañas de manera que
todos estos rayos de luz entran a este
ojo que está viendo muy de cerca a este
espejo que iba a ver este ojo pues este
rayo de luz lo va a extender hacia atrás
su cerebro va a imaginarse que esto
viene de una fuente que está derecha y
lo mismo sucede para este otro rayo que
viene acá entonces esto es lo va a
extender
en este punto de que va a extrapolar lo
de manera que va a estar o lo va a
visualizar en este punto del espejo por
lo que terminará viéndose a sí mismo
este ojo
más o menos así como ven mis dibujos no
son los mejores al día de hoy pero
ustedes tienen una idea en general y sus
diagramas se usan para imaginar cuál
sería la imagen virtual cuando a la luz
de un objeto se refleja por un espejo o
pasa a través de una lente hablaremos
más sobre esto en futuros vídeos y
espero que este vídeo les haya ayudado a
comprender este concepto y nos veremos
en el siguiente